all right Dan wanted me to get drunk to
do the drunk reclines
yeah you know it gets less painful the
drunker you are oh wait
I'm super drunk I'm about to record will
you text me back and let me know if I
sound drunk to you do I sound drunk
right now
text me back talk to you soon this could
be where I cute you guys are watching
this your indicators and I was where was
I oh [ __ ] the alcohol is cutting through
my ability to [ __ ] act doesn't have
to be on script it's fine okay I don't
know world in there why I don't know
world under why I don't know world in
there I don't know where Lindner why
that's not good either okay hold on
sorry I almost threw up there I'm gonna
[ __ ] it I can't say [ __ ] that much we'll
just bleep it isn't that [ __ ] weird
that we can say [ __ ] as much as we want
but then we want to say [ __ ] or [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] count your pennies bro
count your pennies now you guys are
realizing realizing why this [ __ ]
method acting [ __ ] that Harmon wanted to
do is a bad idea because we're such
fragile creatures the human race or just
any living thing everything every living
thing is a [ __ ] delicate it's just
like one punch away from like finding
out what happens after you die [ __ ]
god it's crippling the [ __ ]
immortality we're [ __ ]
we're all gonna die don't you understand
mine 119 Aloha if there's any stragglers
in the last room tell them to get out
over here get over here quick cuz that
last roofs filling up with boys and rats
and gas you guys are teaching me a very
dangerous lesson that I don't need to be
sober to record the voice voices I'm
gonna just get [ __ ] sick drunk every
[ __ ] episode from now on they say
Aloha means hello and goodbye
but the theme of this Hawaii has nothing
to do with this puzzle even this away
one more time I have to need another
shot just kidding joking this is gonna
be the [ __ ] wizkid take I'm a whiz
kid this is the whizz kid take I'm just
a whiz kid he drink a [ __ ] particle
[ __ ] he drink a particle thing I don't
care I'm going home
[Music]
wait let me see how you do Morty's boys
after that oh geez Rick Sony's coming I
can't do this voice anymore I need at
least a week rest a voice suck my big
fat butthole they're drawing it hey
everybody it's Charlie we got new Rick
and Morty there's a whole bunch of
season four stuff going on so we got to
break it down I have a season four
update there's also some deleted scenes
that I'll add to the video after we talk
about season four stuff there's a new
round of that season three blu-ray
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this so big news as you saw
they've been animating it for a while
they just announced who their first
guest star was for season four it's sam
neill of Jurassic Park Fame and a whole
bunch of other stuff we don't know which
episode he did it might be episode 2
episode 3 it's probably from the first
half of the season because if you
remember when they dropped the April
Fool's Day season 3 episode one last
year they had only recently completed
that and they were still polishing the
last couple of episodes as they were
airing new ones later in the summer so
they'll be working on episodes all the
way through next year but as of me
posting this video right now they're
still on track to premiere the season
during July next year the same way they
have the last two seasons they still
haven't confirmed whether it's going to
be 10 episodes or 14 episodes like they
originally intended on season 3 bang
they intended to make the jump to 14
episodes per season starting with season
3 but because there were so many delays
during production and they had some
issues during the back half they had to
cut that to 10 episodes we probably
won't hear about that until they dropped
their first official trailer which I
don't think is gonna be till sometime
early next year they have been posting
jokes from the writers room as they work
on episodes they just posted this 27
dresses story circle if you don't know
what any of those things are 27 dresses
is a rom-com starring Katherine Heigl
the store
Circle is just a joke on Dan Harmon's
famous story circle style of writing The
Simpsons even turned it into a joke a
couple seasons ago but here's that new
deleted scene that they just posted
Morty turned me so we're making icons
[Laughter]
okay it's okay Beth I'm not offended
I understand Morty suspicion this
[ __ ] moment is so [ __ ] good hold
on okay oh my god okay okay mm-hmm okay
no Beth it's okay I'm not offended I
understand Morty suspicion I've misled
him before Morty turned me so we're
making eye contact one more time it's
okay Beth I'm not offended I understand
Morty suspicion okay and he's doing it
again
I'm so [ __ ] great okay mm-hmm no it's
okay Beth I'm not offended I understand
Morty suspicion I've misled him before
Morty turned me so we're making oh my
god
Christ okay [ __ ] turn me so we're
making eye contact line okay all right
okay
Maury turned me so we're making eye
contact no it's okay Beth I'm not
offended
I understand Morty suspicion I've misled
him before Morty turn me so we're making
eye contact this next one's gonna be
hard to to get through okay Morty all
right all right
[ __ ] okay hmm Morty [ __ ] okay um no more
all right Morty I assure you I would
never find a way to get out of Family
Therapy what do you think about that I
turned myself into a pickle pickle Rick
great episode obviously that's really
funny but the interesting thing is is
that normally when people mess up like
that they just leave that on the cutting
room floor they don't animate it because
it takes so much work it's not like a
blooper reel from a live-action
television series an animator actually
has to go through the work of animating
all this stuff so this is actually
pretty cool they went above and beyond
to do it if they drop any more clips or
we get any more news about season four I
will totally make a video about it but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
congratulations Sandra Hansen you're the
giveaway winner from my last Rick and
Morty video please email me on the about
page on my channel so I can get your
details click here to rewatch that
season 4 trailer and click here for the
brand-new Captain Marvel trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]